Rochelle Stauss calls out the People's
Choice Awards claiming she wasn't
allowed to bring her partner g-flip as
her date I have to be honest at this
point I'm just you know it's a little
freeing that my life has you know I
don't really have anything to hide at
this point the selling Sunset star took
to Twitter to air her grievances about
it she tweeted I am on the sauce a bit
so I'll probably regret this later but
People's Choice didn't allow me to bring
my partner to the awards I could only
bring a plus one if it was a cast member
WTF sure this means I will never be
nominated again but honestly F you
People's Choice
[Music]
thank you to everyone that voted
um I have no expectation of taking
anything home tonight our show's been
off the air for a while
um but it's always such an honor and
like flattering to be nominated
grouchelle walked the red carpet solo
she was nominated in the reality TV star
of 2022 category which ultimately went
to Khloe Kardashian the Kardashians cast
also beat out selling sunset for the
reality show of 2022 award you guys
thank you so so much to everyone who
voted for me for our family I'm sure
most of it was you despite losing
Rochelle seemed to be enjoying the night
with her co-stars at an after party
of chocolate caramel and butterscotch
we're gonna start a girl band but
shortly after krisha shared that
although she was nominated she wasn't
permitted her own plus one to the award
show she also claimed some of her
co-stars were allowed to bring plus ones
who were not in the Netflix cast
Rochelle adds that g-flip isn't in the
country and wouldn't have been able to
attend but she had been fighting to
bring them reality star ended her tweets
writing quote I get it there are way
bigger issues but these are the things
that people normally don't say out loud
unless they have multiple correspondence
receipts and have had one too many
Tequilas and dgaf I think when really
terrible things happen to you it
actually helps you soak in those good
moments even more because you don't take
them for granted Rochelle and G flip
first went public with their romance in
May after she starred in the musician's
steamy music video for their song get me
out of here
the project came out nearly a week after
grachell confirmed they're a real life
couple I recently have been spending a
lot of time time with someone that's
very important to me their name is Keith
lip they're non-binary so they go by
they them Rochelle was also hesitant
about sharing details about her new
relationship but ultimately she's happy
about it I'm still very attracted to
masculine energy and and a good human
okay I hear people talk about these
things and they're like I knew from a
young age and I that's not me I know
being in this position we get judged
constantly yeah but at the end of the
day I I'm I'm so happy and so if if that
angers someone then that's not really my
problem
[Music]